- So.
It was,
was what, '91?
I was what? Maybe 12?
12, 13?
And on Eighth and Union, it's, you know,
Union going down, then
Eighth, then Wilshire.
We're gonna get, you know,
go get some breakfast
in the morning at that Chinese Food Land.
And we always get chicken,
and we all like spread,
like here's one for you,
one for you, one for you.
And we hook it up and everything.
I had a little bowl of rice,
and, you know,
start slaying.
And, our enemies are any given moment,
and back in the nineties, it was like,
the hell with your gang
(mimics gunshot)
Stop don't be shooting.
Well, it was one of them days
where I didn't think it would.
And all I hear is (mimics gunshot)like oh,
you know, just jumping out like, whoa,
and all my homies is just gone quick.
Well, as I'm trying to
dig, you know, leave from,
the spot where the war
is hot, I hear "Spooky."
Turn around.
Oh no, I'll go to the homie.
And he goes, tell me, tell me I'm okay.
I go, hey, my boy, my boy, hey, chill out
chill out, chill out, chill
out, chill out, chill out.
(shushes) You know, someone call 911.
I had no phone.
Damn, when you call for
911, not no one around.
Well, can someone fucking call 911?
Just hanging in there with the homie.
I just, you know,
what,
just convertase with him.
Motivate him.
You're gonna be okay.
He's bleeding from his mouth.
You're like looking
not, looking at the one,
look at it but like,
you're gonna be all right.
You know, I miss those
daysxx, is it too much for me?
Or he's going through too much,
like save him but how?
You know.
Ambulance showed up, you
know, when they masked him
on his face, you see the little,
you know, he's breathing.
A little heart relief there, okay.
"Are you related?"
"That's, I'm his friend."
"You know his mom and dad?"
"No, we have no idea.
"This been, we have no idea."
I can't really,
I gotta go, let the parents know.
Well, then we'll do
that because, you know,
you can't roll it on a
related family members.
No, I understand.
So stepbrother, you know, ambulance
and the ambulance took my
homeboy to the general hospital.
Here we are as you know, huh?
We have no ride, so what
do we do, take the bus?
"Which bus are we gonna get?"
"I don't know, this went wrong."
Fighting for the bus, man.
Pick this one up with it, you know.
By the dam, Riverbed in,
and with the mission all
the way straight down there.
Come on, man, hurry up.
Here we are like little
Little Rascals out there, going out there.
To see if the homie is okay
Well we all get to general
hospital almost at two, three
in the morning and the
security and the doctor's like,
whoa what's going on ?
We were like, at least seven of us.
And we ask this
at home where, okay, who's
your, who's your homeboy.
I, you know, I'm out in the
hallway sporty and is us.
We don't know no sporty.
And one of the homies
home for his real name.
He goes, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I hold on it.
The nurse called the doubt and you know
And the nurse heard from the other nurse,
tell them, you know where he was at.
Okay. And she goes, Oh, is this
is his mom and dad are here.
And this is when I say lie.
No, they're not.
They're not here, but we're at home.
You know, we're as friends.
We wanna know if he's okay.
I can't get this information out.
Basically. You just telling
me that he's, you know
but as again you know what I mean?
You know, here I am guessing.
Guess who like, well
now we have to call them
and I don't know the number
but she couldn't tell me
the information that what
I didn't want to hear, but not
even within 20 minutes later
the mom and dad show up.
When they show up, they look at me
and all the homies in which
one of you does to my son
We were, I was scared like a bitch
You know what I mean?
Cause when I say I wasn't,
I'm from I'm from my hood
and I'm, you know, let the homie down .
Bad enough passed away.
Gang-banging
Don't get shot.
Don't get staffed.
Slow your roll.
It's probably the game I afraid from that.
I don't want to get killed but hey,
you know what time it is?
You know, I can't get soft.
Nah, this is like this game.
But the reality of is seeing
the family just break down.
Thank God that wasn't you,
do you think that now?
Because you're being seen going,
Hey, on your stripes right?
wipe them tears ain't just
say it's gonna be okay.
I wish it was that easy as a kid.
On the next one
my home boy negro
I'm at the park.
We're playing handball.
Two other homies that we didn't even know
were just going to get playing a good game
in Santa Fe Springs by
the river bay right there.
Right off the freeway.
Drinking some beers,
we're drinking some
beers, having a good time.
Talking about the good
old days were youngsters.
Hey bro, man, we're just doing the thing.
And as you're playing a
game eight homeless refills
from you hear it once you're
playing the game on the ball
bam, bam, bam.
You know you're doing it.
You know, you get a rally.
Where are you from? They said
Now I'm thinking it's
like, it's another gang.
Oh, there's probably
probably someone else up.
And I asked you again.
Oh wait, Whoa, Whoa.
The ball hit once the ball hit twice.
That's my point.
You didn't hear that.
He's more rubber.
The game that I heard about click,
On the wrong page.
I turned around to look that
Gulf where he's facing him.
(mimics gunshot)
my homeboy just goes down.
Boom backwards.
I was like, come on fool.
I'm going to chase him with a gun.
Dig or be
with the homie right there
and be like, this is to me.
Is this chapter two?
But this one.
Hey Fu I'm all right.
I'm all right.
- Hey, call.
You know he had a phone call nine one one.
No.
- Now what do you mean?
No, let's go forward.
- You had a little bucket car.
You drive.
I got you.
He wants to go to the house.
Why? For what?
He wanted to have the house
because he wanted to get the gun.
I roll with him.
Get the gun.
I'm not the stupidest man, but he looks
like he's getting a
little more like slower.
- I'm killing my own homeboy,
but he wants to, you know
he's older than me, but
still at the my point
- He's like, you know, save his life.
If I even put anything ACE
folks don't even do that.
Let me just come on.
Let's do it.
Well, when we got into the
car and the whole boy goes
I got this on my, just put his head down.
Just went down that part right there.
I knew when he, when he put his head down
I know he was gone.
I can bring know about the life.
If I know that the bullet
go, it got somewhere inside.
You know what I'm saying
is the first time it's
it's a bad memory.
And the second time
only makes you stronger.
If the first one didn't bring you down.
The second ones that make you
like now I know why I
don't want to go there.
Now. I don't want to do that.
Now you don't have to do it.
It comes to you.
We were playing handball once again.
Why didn't he have to put the gun at me?
It wasn't my time.
Huh? The last one, 14 years old.
We also
- I also wanted to, you
know, to prove a point
you know that he's done for his hood.
I don't have a problem with that.
I know you're down on.
I know you're dying.
I know.
You know, you don't rank
up for nothing homes.
Sometimes you got to put all you got
into it just don't that you know you
either gonna also you,
either homie right there.
I was brought up.
I being real thing real.
Don't be fake.
If you have the good to say,
don't say anything at all.
I was always raised with respect.
What's respect, greeting
people, telling people.
Yes, please.
No, thank you.
Excuse me.
Bless you.
- It just hurts.
- Like it's kind in front
of you and you have to
be the one to tell the
Foundry of what happens.
. It's so hard to do to see the mom don't
know what it took you
to slap you in the dag
grabbed you by the throat.
Oh boy.
- At the funeral.
- I still pay my respects
that it wished I was me.
I should be worth it with you, but no
be the smart one off, you
know, get a life, get a life.
Elder gets better rate.
Yeah, for sure.
It does.
- I was in downtown LA Banda.
What am I?
What am I right away?
Enemies was, you know,
18th street and you know
a female that I look at it and like
you know who she had
turned out that, you know
her name was Cisco rest in peace.
And we hooked up.
We hooked up, you know what I mean?
- And where are you from until Ross?
Rama, orphans, orphans.
It's like, Oh God
I know your homeboy is
so-and-so and so-and-so okay.
Cool.
- Is it, you know, we
enemies, but she's like
- Man, don't even trip.
Come on.
Let's go follow me.
All right
cool. Let's go
- Hanging out.
You know, doing the thing
with within downtown LA
- As we're walking in and she
wants to do a little shortcut
- And I'm like, Hey,
hold, hold, hold, hold up.
You know what I mean?
You
- Go there.
I can go through it.
Come on, come on, come on.
- I'm like, nah, let's go the other way.
She insisted
- Man. Come on, hurry up, man.
It's okay.
There's no one around.
It seems too easy just to
just listen to what you said.
And it was like midnight as I follow her.
We'd go down the side street
- In downtown my neighborhood on 18 union.
As I'm walking through my, my neighbor
my enemies neighborhood.
It was Whitmer.
It was a side street by the hotel.
As we're making a left, it was
like an intersection of two streets
and houses as I turn it
through in the middle.
All I hear is though, I look
- Hey almost.
Where are you?
From?
- What? I see, three
foods jumped the fence.
Oh
- I see fools.
Come on the building.
What I say to go downstairs?
Oh.
So homey.
It's a hungry from, I see
more than 15 people came up.
Oh my God.
So, and it hit me.
It was so where are you from here?
She goes, Sysco.
Hey, hold on, hold up.
Shoes in front of me and hold on.
He's a, he's a man.
He's with me.
I'm like AA.
Don't go.
I'm watching my I'm
watching my surroundings.
They surround me.
I can run
- I'm in a dead end.
And when they rushed me,
when they found out where
I was from, when they
rushed me, they punched
- Her. She went down and I'm finding
I'm trying to hit two or three people.
Legs, arms kicked me.
I went down at one.
I went down my head, hit
the concrete pole pole.
I'm like, Oh, the rubbing
my hand, his street.
I'm like, Oh, and they're
kicking me, stomping me.
I'm just like, God help me.
All I hear was, Hey, one time.
Boom. They let go.
- They all got off me.
They all scattered.
- I got up.
I got up my eyes.
I said out loud, just mad.
She was like, shut the up.
I was so mad and I was in tears.
Just get the away from me.
I walk away and I'm going to Bonko
- When he was at house
on seventh and Garland, he was a manager.
- I'm walking.
I'm liberal.
I got blood coming down.
I walked into the I'm walking
into, is this place a deal?
Who is it?
It's me.
Smokey. Hold on
- Opens the door.
Let's man, what
- The hell is wrong with you?
I says, and I got job.
I had blood.
I tried to wash myself up.
I was so much in pain.
I said, man, is this
how it really goes down?
He goes, what happened?
I told her that I went with
Cisco to deal or shortcut, ah
for Benihana's man for, you
know, for not paying attention.
See what happens.
And I says, man, I'm looking at it.
I didn't get killed.
He goes, you're looking
at it and kill you.
I said, man, I was just, man.
I'm telling you, man, is,
is beyond crazy to survive.
When you got 15 people on
you, they want to kill you
because you, you know,
it's part of the game.
You get caught slipping, you get killed.
- You know, there was another time
in my neighborhood and on and
on eighth and union, you know
- We were all about seven.
All of us from orange County and LA
- All pulse up right there by union.
Just post it up, you know,
just listen to the radio and
everything. Sure enough
- On the street and, you know,
our neighborhood.
Like, all right.
All right, whatever man.
We're about to around.
What's the about what's
up man, man, shine.
- The mom.
Sure enough
man. We're looking at
- One, two, one seven, eight fools
- Man. Food's got a the
club things for the cars.
Food had a, a wooden stick.
What a bat
- I said, Hey, I wish I homeys.
Oh man.
They brought their load.
Man. When we went at it with these foods
these foods were swinging
where we're moving away.
We're like, Whoa, Whoa,
Whoa, swinging my home.
I gets hit in the back pole.
I said, Hey, what the hell?
I swear the crowbar.
It swears, boom.
He's going to face almost a year out.
I go down bombing on the bottom.
I hit him in the bed with a crowbar.
Boom. I get cracking back on my skull.
I'm like, we're fighting.
We're all bloody and funny.
I don't know what it is in LA.
By when the surroundings see going down
they always say leprosy
- Everyone just kind of walked away.
My homeboy was up in Olympian.
I grabbed them, get them up.
- Come on my boy.
I said, man, this was gang
bangs all about on me.
I said, I mean, I cannot
tell you any more, but I mean
. You know
- You know me, myself in, in
my gang banging days, I was
you know, I was serving
and you know, it was one
of these nights where I
had, I was almost like I was
by myself, in my neighborhood,
no one in the balconies.
And it turned out this one,
Pfizer as one Peiser came down.
And when he came down, he came down
Hey you want to buy some material?
I go, go to get
- It. And I go, Hey
- Come on.
I'm not prescient.
- I said, well, what's up, man?
What do you, I mean, let me see him.
I don't know.
Pick up a shirt.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Hey, I want to buy some rock.
All right, homie.
How much you I buying?
I want, won't buy 200 with the rug.
200. Ooh.
Okay. All right.
Hold on.
- You know what I mean?
So I kind of played off him,
not knowing I had, I had
I had a strap behind my back.
You know what I mean?
It was, it was, it was, it
was 38 and may 14, 14 or 15.
And this guy wanted to buy
material, but he looked really
he had a sweater on a t-shirt sweating.
He had like medium haircut.
He just looked real oily, just look real.
Like it was just real
stinky and he insisted
- And come on, where's it at?
Okay. Let me hold on.
- Well, back then our, our,
our, our material was in foil
wrapped up.
You know
you have to open up like
this in the falls inside and
- Hey, come on, come on.
I said, hold on.
Where's the money at?
He goes, let me say, Hey,
this guy pulls out a machete.
And I looked like, Whoa, gimme, gimme it.
Hey, hold on, hold on, hold over.
And when he swung, I hear that damaged.
He goes, I said, Whoa, Whoa,
Whoa, hold on, hold on, hold
on. I'm looking around.
Not one of my homeboys
- Is around.
I'm by myself and he insisted
- One of my time.
I'm going to kill you.
Hold up, hold up, hold up, hold up.
Hold on.
Okay. Okay, go, go
go. Hey, hold on.
You want it?
You want it right here.
As, as he's looking, I'm not looking.
I threw it to him, his eyes follow it up.
- And his eyes looked down
when his eyes looked down
Oh man was on Jude.
Rush him with a machete, try to be a hero.
And like that.
I mean
- He didn't know, but it was off safety.
- I mean, I did it.
That smart thing.
I threw it up.
He followed it.
And when, when, when, when
his eyes hit the ground
the machete was not even
letting her to, to, to hit me.
And when he looked, when I
when he lifted it and looked
go down, I leaned back.
I grabbed it.
Like I'm not going to fall back.
- Boom, boom, boom.
It flew once.
Get side of his head, took off
- Almost half of his head
and he goes down his knees
and he falls down and I'm just
like, I gotta get outta here.
I gotta get out of here.
As I'm running, I'm
running from downtown LA.
My boy does in South central,
I cage him nine me on down.
Who knows what medication I was on.
Some drugs.
I straight went from
Broadway and to Broadway
all the way down, running, running.
I kid you not.
I had my strap on me when
I was running so much.
My whole body was just oily, just shiny.
I was taking out my shirt.
I was so hot cops on the other side of the
Island were driving.
Look, once, look towards like,
who's that guy right there.
Didn't even pull me over.
As I get to my boys pad, they're like
what's wrong with you?
So out of breath and it turned
out that, Hey, what happened?
I explained to him what happened and well
let's go back home and don't trip on trip.
You know what I mean?
I took care of it.
Well, we're the homies at?
Let's just say I was by myself.
You know, there's times
in my life where I thought I
had my homework to get my back.
Sometimes you got 'em sometimes you don't.
But what I learned is gang-banging
since I was 12 years old until now
is that you're with it or you're not.
And when someone is so
serious to take someone's life
they want to hesitate and
they'll take your life like that.
And you're through.
And it was so sad about it.
As people walk away like, Oh, he's dead.
I'm gone
- Man. You didn't want
to help him like that.
Like, like, man, it's a cold world.
When I came out of prison and I found out
- That, you know, my girl was killed
in a drive by I investigated that.
And when I investigated to
find out who, who you know
who you know, who did the
drive-by turned out 18th street.
Okay. What are the odds
are triple G slacks
grade three, color, three color, low
a dress shirt, gray hair,
mustache trim the housing.
This is going to here.
- It goes, Hey Holmes.
You spooky, man.
Who are you?
Holmes. He picked
- Up his shirt and it had the one eight
- One homie.
He was here the wrong neighborhood on me.
And want me to get it home?
You know
- I want to talk to you Holmes.
I heard what happened with your lady.
Okay.
- Jimmy, my lady on me, wait, what's up.
You know what I mean?
- He goes, Hey homie
I could relate to what
happened to your lady.
But my lady dad had cancer.
- What is that going to do with me
homes? Because
- The homies that did that were stupid,
the homie should have
done that because they
hit a six year old boy.
And that was uncalled for
the little boy survived.
And then we heard about
your lady and a friend
got killed too in the, in
the, in the drive-by so
- Well, he told me about
who did it, of his homeboys.
I go back right in my hallways.
Hey Fu Hey, come on.
He backed me up, back me up.
- Sure. Loud dog out on me.
It's all right.
- I was so off.
Cause not one of them
want to help me, man.
They look at me like, are
you set, tripping on me?
you fools.
Hey. How mean if it was your
lady that got killed over here
they want to help me.
And your might even my neighborhood.
I was
- Tears. I was so mad.
- I went out of my building, went
- Into a parking lot, had some crystal.
I had a syringe.
I slam your shot.
Like Omar to kill myself.
That shot
- Was way too much
where I thought I should
- Have died.
But by the grace of God, God
goes, it's not your time.
That shot hit me.
So hard reading so hard.
- Dan, why don't you kill me?
Why, why?
Why can I
- So what happened was
I strap my thinking.
I'm gonna do it myself.
I'm going to their neighborhood.
How might I do it?
I said, I'm walking an old man
with a shopping cart, like a bum.
- I mean that long trench coat man.
And he goes right.
Oh man, man, I got crack.
All right, man, no problem.
Not trying to go with me.
He put it on me
- But you know what I mean?
I put it on me, Sean, some crack
- Air, man.
Let me, Oh, I'll be right here, man.
I be man, whatever
- Cool gain.
What he wanted in the shop of code.
It was a newspaper, a lot of
radios and bottles, whatever.
As I'm writing it, I'm
writing it like this
on the shopping cart that I
felt like I'm drunk, whatever.
I'm just the trench coat
with a, with a collar up.
And I'm just like that.
All I hear is boom,
boom, boom, boom, boom.
Here I here.
I have bumping turns out right there
and right there in the
neighborhood on, on Alvarado.
But I don't shop right there.
It had four doors open and
the guy was cleaning his car.
Two ladies were on top of the porch.
Like I was cleaning his car and three
his homeboys right there.
And all of a sudden when they
see, when they hear the noise
of the cart, making that noise, that
that other loud noise
of the shopping cart.
- Hey, Hey, don't make,
get the out of here, man.
Hey man.
Sure enough.
Here they come.
My man.
the.
Who the are you, man?
I ain't get the phone call on
my neighborhood neighborhood.
They were trying to pump.
- If you think about
it, they kick the car.
- Are the cart falls over.
They bumped pumped me with the elbows.
Boom. I fall down.
Oh man.
You know what I mean?
The car they kick over the radio.
The bottles are rolling on the street.
You know what I mean?
Man. Get the out of here, man.
You like that.
The coat, when it fell down,
it kind of just lit up.
So they couldn't see my face.
The guy was cleaning the car.
Hey homie, get over here man.
man, come on, get over here man.
Come on.
- Always playing turn around.
All right.
Right, right.
As soon as he turned around
and we're walking back
I pull my thing out and I just started
- Oh, Oh, the girls started screaming
- The guy's window.
He was cleaning window shattered guy.
Who
- Was the bagpipe?
Ah, ah, boom.
- I'm hitting him.
I'm hitting him.
I left the whole
- Go, boom, boom, boom, boom.
At that
- They got down the guy that
walked the car, he got away
but that's them three that came over.
You're trying to poke me.
They went down.
When I ran from downtown
I had to go back to downtown center.
- What is it?
South central.
I have one of my homes
down in South central.
That was always
- He was my partner, man.
He was always there for me.
But I, in a situation like
that, I'm just thankful today
that you know, I don't
got no murder charge.
It just there's some that goes down.
It was just like, you know, Mount homeboy
eight other times, the
neighborhood homes now, Hey
you know what happened?
Hey, you know, you know,
you know how it is?
Why, what, you know, someone got blasted
- For real.
They stupid
- what happened, you
know, you know how it is.
I've gotta put in work,
all put in, work on
- Oh, I sat there as
they try to take credit
- For something that they didn't do.
When I know what I did.
- It's always good to know
what you do, but don't
- Spread your business out
there to keep it to yourself.
You learn something, you know what I mean?
You know, it's just that
in my life that what I've
been doing, I've been
through a lot of experiences
and I'm just trying to tell
taking it one day at a time.
And this is when I was six
years of being out of prison.
I thank God for that.
I'm not trying to go
backwards and go forward.